So now I do want to play for you just some
clips of Donald Trump's doctor, Sean Connelly,
deceiving and juking and disorienting the public
over the weekend about Donald Trump's health. So
on Saturday morning, Sean Connelly came out with
an army of doctors standing behind him to tell
us everything is supposedly great except that he
didn't. This was one of the biggest disasters in
crisis management. He created a crisis by coming
out and obviously lying about how great everything
is going. It started to get weird with Dr. Sean
Connelly when he was asked whether Donald Trump
had been on supplemental oxygen. And Connelly
insisted Trump didn't need oxygen that day.
You have one more time. I know you said there is
no oxygen today. It was evening on Thursday and
he's today said Saturday. No, no, Thursday.
There's enough on Saturday. That's what I
said. That was my work Thursday. No oxygen.
None at this moment. Yeah. And yesterday
with the team. Well, while we were
all here, he was not on oxygen.
So he says none Thursday, none at Walter Reed
Friday and none today, which was Saturday. Now,
of course, now we know Trump had oxygen Friday
at the White House. Really bad lying. It was
obvious that Sean Connelly was lying. Sean
Connelly also mentioned and this might be a
case of accidentally telling the truth. Sean
Connelly mentioned Trump had now been. This
was Saturday morning. Connelly said Trump had
been in treatment 72 hours. Wait a second. 72
hours from Saturday morning. That puts us Friday
morning, Thursday morning, Wednesday morning.
Publicly, Donald Trump supposedly didn't
test positive till one a.m. Friday morning.
He's been in treatment for 72
hours. That's weird. Take a listen.
As reported yesterday,
consultation with this group,
I recommended we bring the president up to
Walter Reed as a precautionary measure to provide
state of the art monitoring and any care that he
may need. Just 72 hours into the diagnosis now,
the first week covered and in particular
day seven to 10 of the most critical.
Later, Connelly put out a
statement saying, I made a mistake.
I just made a mistake about how long it had been.
Not very convincing for the doctor who supposedly
has been involved in Trump's treatment every step
of the way. Connelly also said Trump had no fever
for a while. Minutes later, we got a report
that Trump had a fever that day. Lies, lies,
lies. And when the pressure got to be too much,
when it became abundantly clear that they were
lying. Dr. Sean Connelly came out again on Sunday
and seemed very confused about how time works and
what day it is seeming to have almost of issues
better served for a physics lab that than than for
a medical press conference. How does time work?
Does it go forward or backwards? Only raising more
questions about the accuracy of the story that we
are getting here is Connally being asked about his
vague admission that Trump did have some breathing
problems. But everything is fine nonetheless.
There were two instances where he drops in oxygen.
Can you walk us through the second one? And also,
I had a question for the lung specialist.
Yeah. Yesterday there is another episode where he
dropped down 93 percent. Here's an ever feel short
of breath. We watched it and it returned back up.
They said we reevaluate all of this. And given
the timeline where he is in the course of illness,
you know, we really are trying to maximize
everything that we could do for him. And we
debated whether we'd even started the next AmEx's
dexamethasone. And we decided that in this case,
the potential benefits early on the course
probably outweighed any risks at this time.
Did you give him a second round
of supplemental oxygen yesterday?
I'd have to I'd have to check with the nursing
staff. I don't think that if he did, it was very,
very limited. But he's not on oxygen. And the only
oxygen that I ordered or that we provided was that
Friday morning. Initially, about what time was, I
guess, yesterday at what was yesterday, you said
the second instance, second chance incidents
over the course of the day. Yesterday morning.
Yesterday what? Oh, yeah. Yesterday it was during
the course of the day. Yesterday morning. Well,
wait, hold on. Was it in the morning or was it
throughout the day? What are you talking about?
Even Connelly himself sounds confused, like he's
obviously lying, like he's been told to downplay.
But he also seems confused about the facts.
In the next moment, I'm going to play for you.
Connelly is called out for saying Trump's doing
great. And then minutes later, Trump's chief of
staff, Mark Meadows, came out and admitted to
the media, it's really bad. We're not even sure
Trump will make a full recovery at this point in
time. Connelly called out about it. And here's
how he how he responded. The steroids.
Sarah told us that the president was in
great shape happening, that she'd been
fever free for the previous 24 hours.
Minutes after your press conference, White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows told reporters that
the president's vitals were very concerning. Over
the past 24 hours. Simple question about whose
statements about the president's health.
So the chief and I worked side by side
and I think his statement was misconstrued. What
he meant was that 24 hours ago when he and I were
checking on the president, that there was
that momentary episode of the high fever
and that temporary drop in the saturation
which prompted us to act expediently to move
him up here. Fortunately, that was really a very
transient, limited episode. A couple hours later,
he was back up mild again. You know, I'm not going
to speculate what that that limited episode was
about so early in the course, but he's doing well.
You really get the sense that Connally is just not
cut out for this lying. He's doing the line, but
he's doing it really poorly and transparently.
Nobody believes this guy at this point. Check
this one out. Remember from our last segment
that oxygen saturation below 94 is serious
covered. That's the baseline. Connelly is asked,
was Trump ever saturating oxygen below
90? And Connelly says, we don't have
recordings of that here at the hospital.
Kind of a weird response. So then he's asked,
was oxygen saturation ever below 90? And
Connelly says it was never in the low 80s.
Nobody asked about the low 80s. Another
obvious lie ever dipped below 90.
We don't have any recordings here of that.
That's right. Dexamethasone. Yeah. But here
at the White House or hear anything below 90,
just to follow up on our question, no. Is below
94 percent. It was it wasn't down in the low 80s
or anything. So. Okay, it's on the DEXA method.
It is lie after lie. And from that, what I
interpret is Trump's saturation did get to the
80s, not the low 80s. And that's really serious
covered. And then lastly, here he is explaining
the previous day's absurd,
rosy picture that he painted.
He just says, well, I was trying to be upbeat.
The day that the president had been administered
oxygen took a question.
So I was trying to reflect
the the the upbeat attitude that the team, the
president, of course, of illness has had. I
didn't want to give any any information that might
steer the course of illness in another direction.
And in doing so, you know, came off that we're
trying to hide something that wasn't really true.
I love that he says there. I mean, it's just every
sentence, every he says we weren't necessarily
trying to hide something. It's almost like a
Freudian use of the word necessarily. You weren't
necessarily trying to hide something, but you
were. But what what does that even mean? They lie
about everything. And we have to ask why. And the
answer is optics. Given that there's an election
in 30 days or less. I think it's 29 days at this
point, 28 days period. Has Donald Trump gotten to
the point where they're going to send him back
to the White House? You might know him no more
than I've been able to tell you now. Because
something may have changed in the next few hours.
We will follow it. We will cover it.
They are very, very worried here about
the impact of this on the election. And
we'll talk about that after the break.
The David Pakman Show at David
Pakman dot com. The David Pakman Sho